welcome to the omr podcast last year we
spoke a lot about soccer this year we've
been talking speaking a lot about the
formula one it starts with one of the
biggest names in formula one he's um
the mastermind behead behind formula one
um red bull racing he's christian horner
he doesn't speak german his name sounds
german but he's british hi christian
hi
um
explain to us a little bit about your
journey into formula one i mean
everybody knows your name and video your
household name almost in germany um but
i don't think everybody knows like the
way how you got there
yeah well as you say i have a german
sounding name but uh unfortunately
um you know i've lived in the uk all my
life i'm not aware of any german
heritage but i started my career as a
driver you know i started racing in
in carts when i was uh 11 years of age
um
then i progressed into into car racing
in racing you know single seater race
cars so full of through the various
formulas formula renault formula three
formula two um
and uh
i created my own team in formula two
um
and i raced for it for for two seasons
just to get it established
and then um
you know really ran the team as i would
have liked to have driven for a team and
um
you know i had a lot of success with
that i won the championship for three
years in a row uh racing against uh
dr helmut marco's team ah
ah okay this is my first uh well even
before that was my first introduction
you know to him i bought a trailer from
him back in 1996 when i first created
this team
and um
and yeah and then i ran a red bull
junior driver in 2004
uh with antonio liozi uh alongside
dutchman robert dornboston um
again dominated that championship
um so i was looking at the next step you
know to go into into formula one um
bernie ecclestone was pushing me very
hard
to buy what was at the time the jordan
team
um
and i was had some investors that were
interested in getting involved in that
uh and then rebel
became the primary option for uh the
jaguar team
um and once they'd acquired it at the
end of in november 2004 they came to me
and said
well look why don't you come into this
project with us
and uh because they wanted to change the
management and put their own mark on it
and so
uh the deal with uh jordan beckett was
becoming ever more complicated
so i decided that
you know i'd go for i'd take up this
position with you know with red bull i
was only 31 years of age
um
so it was uh it was an exciting project
to be and get involved in you know right
from from the from the very beginning
but you never became an investor into
the team right i mean like your other
option would have been to like
look for money yourself and become an
entrepreneur yourself like the way it's
set up now my understanding is
you are basically in the end is at an
employee position within red bull how
would you consider that yeah no
absolutely so i'm you know i'm the ceo
and team principal of uh the red bull
formula one activities where the
shareholders
you know 100 shareholders are our rebel
gmbh so uh yeah i report to
mr matterships and uh
you know obviously the the board in uh
in in red bull but did you sometimes
regret that you don't became an investor
yourself i mean
there was such a value development
around those teams lately yeah but
formula one's a very expensive game also
and i think that you know the value is
really coming into the franchises now
um and
you know it would have been
just too expensive
uh in the previous years to get involved
in you know in the sport the uh the
demand for for
sponsorship and revenue is so high
it would have been very very difficult
to uh have made for example the jordan
project you know successful at the time
what kind of cost were you looking at
for a team at that stage uh like a
couple of years ago and versus today
what's like just
be able to understand it economically a
little bit better what type of value are
we looking at
i think at the time you were talking
about evaluation
of the jordan team
you know eddie was trying to value it
around 15 16 million pounds so uh and if
you think you know today's teams
the top team is is in excess of a
billion
uh
wow so that would be the red bull team
now or the mercedes team is like
overbearing you've got to assume that
with where formula one is with the
revenues that come into the sport
that uh
you know in in excess of that you know
for for a top team wow wow
and um maybe one last question to you to
your journey to your past um
like your talent as a driver was that
would that been would have been enough
to drive in formula one yourself like
like open and self-critical
were you just like the wrong
circumstances or would you say like
you're a better manager than a driver
i was okay as a driver but there were
lots of drivers that were okay you know
i raced against
my era was juan pablo montoya and
nick heidfeld and
you know guys
guys like that but uh
you know i the higher you get the harder
it becomes
and you know i was okay but i was only
ever average i was not a good enough to
be a
a good formula one driver i tested in
formal one for the lotus team
back in the early 90s in 1990
at
but uh it greatly gave me a fantastic
insight it gave me you know a great
experience
and a feeling and understanding
okay but i mean it would have been
enough for like the middle or the back
of the field or the pack but not full
like be a championship driver absolutely
even the middle uh even the middle of
the pack that the standard in fallon is
so high
um the you know i i i loved the time
that i had driving i drove against some
great uh
you know great drivers um
you know some wonderful talent at the
time drivers like tom christensen was
racing and um
uh
who else uh you know i was racing in
cards against yellow truly and yeah and
uh jeff carlos keller and these guys and
actually um
yeah i raced against max verstappen's
mum
uh
sophie clunk
uh in the very late 80s 1989 i did the
world championships in karting and uh
was racing against
you know max's mother
okay i didn't know that okay um i mean
i'm asking a little bit because it
sometimes feels like there is a path to
formula one as a driver um that that is
basically money i mean you there's those
those paid drivers where you know
there's always these stories of people
that sort of like buy a seat and it
feels like
you know that is not a talent question
then i know i think formula one uh or
motorsport is just genuine generally
very expensive from karting all the way
through and you know i had to work very
hard to
raise sponsorship um to fund you know my
my driving career so again it was
another education for me that you know i
had to go and and sell myself i had to
uh sit in front of
you know company management and and
convince them to to invest in me to
invest in in in motor racing so that was
again it was great experience and then
then running the team
um
you know i'd be booking the hotels i'd
be doing the tax returns i'd be paying
the salaries
helping to wash the truck you know you
know you um
you you do all the jobs and i think it's
it was a great education for me because
uh
you get to experience all aspects you
know of running and operating a team
what what's the the team like today i
mean what what kind of company are we
looking at in terms of revenue or
employees um just give us a feeling of
what what type of economic you thing
we're looking at there
well you see rebel is such a big entity
in formula one and of course we have
you know rebel racing we have rebel
power trains now the new venture for for
the future formula one engine we have
rebel advanced technology we have the
this company encompassing america's cup
and the valkyrie
and and other projects and then of uh we
have rebel technology which is the uh
supplier of technology to
alpha tori as well as our own grand prix
team so there's many
different
divisions of you know within the rebel
formula group
uh but you know it employs
approximately
you know 1 200 people wow okay
you know we have
revenues that are probably around
you know half a billion euros
you know per annum so it's it's a big
business it's a competitive business and
of course it's diversified
from not just formula one but into other
projects like you know designing the
valkyrie like the america's cup project
like you know bikes that we're working
on with bmc and
and so on so um
it's it's fascinating how the business
has really you know evolved from what
red bull bought from jaguar at the end
of 2004.
and the america's cup that's sailing
then is that the sailing project
rebula lingi
uh partnership so we're supplying you
know technology and know-how to that
project
um you know with a specialist um
knowledge that we have whether it be
simulation or on
aerodynamics for example for example
okay and and what's the main revenue
source is that sponsoring in the end we
have a significant amount of uh
sponsorship revenue um
you know approaching you know half the
figure that i that i just mentioned and
then of course the television revenues
are
significant um
you know through the distribution of the
price funding formula one so
so um
so and then of course all the different
projects that we and engineering
projects that we have so we have a
combination of of revenue streams okay
but sponsoring this is the most
important one
sponsorship i mean obviously we've
announced
uh a title partner for this year with
with oracle um but then we have a
roster of over you know 20 partners
um
yeah some of which are new for this year
but uh it's a a great um you know makeup
of different partners from
you know all all categories okay okay
how did this grow so much i mean some of
it seems like the general growth of
formula one and the whole industry grew
like it became a really truly global
um sport um
but
i mean what was the main
drivers of that growth
in the competitiveness is important um
being able to offer a a a real um
return on investment is uh you know is
crucial the b to b work is between some
of our partners as well is is a key
factor but then our success success on
track drives that
that interest and then of course
the the uh growing popularity of formula
one um because of the competitive racing
because of
things like netflix that have taken
formula one to the people um you know
we've got a whole new fan base coming in
america has suddenly
fallen in love with formula one and
um and woken up to formula one so that
drives different revenues different
uh you know funding streams into the
business would you attribute that
american other that success in the us to
netflix mostly i rate studies how like
there's not i think two races already
happening in the us i'm thinking about a
third one um there's like so much
tv interest in the us now is that all
because of netflix in the end i think
fundamentally it's because the show has
been good and the racing has been
competitive but you see what
uh
you know something like netflix does is
it
it gives you a glimpse behind the scenes
into the characters and the
personalities of the drivers and the
teams and the competition and i think
it's really ignited you know the
interest in america and we've seen that
go exponential the last you know the
last few years so um so yeah i would say
netflix has played a key role in in
bringing in a new fan base and also a
much younger fan base you know into
formula
when you first heard about the project
were you skeptical were you like
immediately were you like okay let's do
that that's awesome
well the first approach was actually to
do it just on red bull
okay so we were talking uh i was talking
to the uh
the production company that produces it
and said they they approached us if they
could spend a year
you know with us as a fly on the wall
uh and then formula one said actually we
don't want to do it with just one team
i want to do it with all the teams and
so they came back to me and said look
you know this is formal one's position
would you be okay with that it's well
it's better you do something than
but nothing
so we were involved
you know very much from the very
beginning um
and in the first year of course
ferrari didn't get involved mercedes
wanted to do their own deal with amazon
um and they stood back and then they saw
the value of
what it brought and then they came in in
series two
okay um i mean you said that
competitiveness the product plays a huge
role i mean even netflix i mean they
have the distribution but they need to
still need something to show like that
that's that's amazing too that catches
people um but i mean now like with the
exception of this year i mean obviously
now this year was was new year um but
the years before it it wasn't that close
it seemed like it's it's an established
ranking almost like the german
bundesliga where you have one champion
and it's the same one every year yeah
and you know serial winning is
is boring it turns people off you know
sport we saw it
and the michael schumacher
era you know um people will claim the
sebastian vettel you know era even
though
two of those championships went to the
last race against fernando lonzo um
but i think that uh
you know
what this series has done is has
definitely ignited the interest and
shown some of the
you know some of the politics some of
the the personalities some of the
challenges
you know behind the scenes that isn't
just based on the racing
okay but i mean you need those sub
stories in order to create tension
because the the big story was always
and so of course then you get a a golden
year like last year the most competitive
year in formula one for the last 40
years where every weekend you had max
and uh lewis
uh like heavyweight boxers fighting
you know across 22 different rounds and
that then is
you know box office for
for the the promoters the broadcasters
uh you know and and and uh
sitters like uh netflix
i mean how much was the last year
different than the years before in terms
of attention was there like twice the
attention was it i mean can you is there
any any uh proxy that you can that you
can mention whether you're like okay
it's totally changed like the last year
was it was like on a different level
yeah last year was way more intense when
we won the world championship with
sebastian it was it was tough but it was
all about what was going on the track
um and uh it was stressful but it was
nothing like the intensity of you know
last year last year there was
so much politics away from the circuit
um
and so much tension on the circuit and
it was so close between the two teams
the two drivers and of course the
mercedes have dominated everything the
previous seven seasons so
um
nobody had challenged them
you know like uh like like we had and so
uh
the intensity of that battle was
you know was huge all the way to the
final race which then in itself had its
own controversies uh you know
surrounding it but you know to come out
of the year
beating lewis and becoming world
champions for for the fifth time as
drive with the driver champion in max um
was an unbelievable season and feeling
for us but i mean even though
sometimes you lose doesn't it feel like
i mean the end the product is good i
mean how much is like the the real
passion for winning and how much is your
passion for just producing a good
product i mean even like the mercedes
guys must know that even though they
lost
they were like part of an awesome
product so so does that does it soothe
it in a little bit or is that is it like
are you like racing guys it's just all
about winning i think
you know if you if you're a competitive
person it's all about winning
and you know red bull is in formula one
because he wants to win he wants to take
on
uh
you know the giants of the sport and
beat ferraris beat mercedes you know
beat the manufacturers and i think you
know we've demonstrated that we can do
that and and we've done that
consistently so uh yeah it's all about
winning and winning drives everything
else your
your bottom line always looks better
when you've got a winning car i mean but
your sponsors or my city sponsors they
must be happy anyways i mean um they got
the attention they got the the reach
they were they were hoping for probably
nevertheless and my question is what do
you pitch them i mean um like how do you
convince somebody to to advertise or to
work with you what's what's i mean
what's the what's the what's the best
argument it's a very compelling story
because i think you know formula one
uh
you know even compared to the olympic
games and the football world cup you
know we generate bigger audiences and i
think and those of course
happen every four years whereas formula
one is every two weeks
um so
you know the demographic of what we
reach the global reach that we have the
the countries that we perform in
um
[Music]
the the the television television
figures that we generate the eyeballs
through social and digital media that we
that we generate um when you're looking
for a return on investment formula one
um
actually is very very cost effective
so for
you know somebody like
an oracle or an exxon mobile or a tag
lawyer or you know particularly for a
rep bull in terms of a marketing
platform
for the reach that formula one has
it's the biggest sporting entity in the
world
festival here in hamburg with thousands
what's the best best placement you can
offer i mean obviously like the team
name now is red bull which is like you
know in itself with the sponsor um but
after that like what's what's usually
with you but in general for me the one
probably the best like the most
important placement that you have
i think title partners so for example
bringing oracle in this year we become
oracle rebel racing
um so they have prominent branding on
the site boards on the drivers and and
so on and so again the
uh
that the eyeballs the coverage that they
will generate through the branding that
they have in all the territories that we
race in and are broadcasting is is
you know is enormous it's monstrously
huge can you like give us an at least an
estimate of what's that worth it like an
oracle is that like a
what is it a nine-figure
investment for them
yeah i mean it's a significant number
for them and it's a long-term uh you
know investment as well and it's great
that an american company like them have
seen the value of formula one and chosen
to invest in of course it's also the
perfect place to showcase their product
their technology their cloud computing
or or you know their fan engagement that
with making use of all of their software
and all of their tools and that applies
to all of our partners you know whether
it's a
you know tag heuer or a poker stars new
for this year or an arctic wolf or a hp
or siemens or
you know the list is
um is you know is pretty lengthy but uh
it's great that we've attracted these
brands
to supplement rebel
and do you um do that like
in terms of outbound sales do you
approach them and tell them look what we
have here don't don't you want to talk
with us or is there like a lengthy
inbound waiting list of people that want
to talk to you and then discuss with you
well we're very fortunate um you know
that we are able to pick and choose the
partners that we want to work with so
you're always looking for the right fit
um
and
you know it's not just about the sticker
on the car sometimes it's about the
technology that's in the car you know as
well so it's about having the right
fit of partners for the brand that we
are
um and uh you know that are like-minded
that share the same goals the same
vision the same the same attributes and
so we're in a fortunate position we can
be a little bit
choosy um particularly in recent times
that you know there's a huge demand for
red bull
what's the role of the driver i mean
understandably the technology plays a
huge role and i mean from the outside
one understands that you can only win
with the right car um so it seems like
the car is is even more important but
then what's the what's the role of the
driver in in general like in for winning
and for for you know becoming a brand
well the driver is a crucial ingredient
you know he's a key part and uh
you know all these drivers are
phenomenally talented but the cream
always rises to the top and i think in
max verstappen we have currently the
best driver in the world um
he is obviously the world champion but i
think as a 24 year old you see he's in
his ascendancy
lewis hamilton the most successful
driver of all time
um
again a phenomenal talent and you saw
those two guys
raise themselves to a different level
last year they were you know
ahead of the whole rest of the field
um
taking blows out of each other every
every um you know race from bahrain to
to abu dhabi and it was a phenomenal
thing to see
um
and the variance that a driver can
create and of course the car is hugely
important and you know they wouldn't
neither lewis nor max would
win in a car that was from p9 or p10 on
the grid
but
you know the cream always rises to the
top and
and those guys set themselves apart from
the rest of the field
at what point can you tell that the
driver is like a red bull driver that
has special talent i mean you know you
just said that like a driver in p8 or p9
can't win i mean how do you identify
like that talent is that just do you see
it and you at the track you stand there
and you notice okay that guy is
different or
what makes you i mean how do you how do
you scout telling that way
well you um we invest a lot in uh young
talent we have a lot of drivers coming
through the junior program so red bull
have always been very active in that
side of thing you know led by
dr helmut marker he's always been very
keen on nurturing and bringing in new
and young and exciting talent so you get
you get an idea as they're coming
through the lower formula but it's not
until they get to formula one that
and indeed they get to a front-running
seat that suddenly the pressure the
scrutiny of the media the the pressure
of being in that seat the expectation
that comes that you see how these
drivers deal with that pressure and you
know they either sink or swim
um
and we do our best to to
train them before they get to that
that uh that level
but a driver like verstappen for example
it's at the big pressure the high
pressure moments that you see them
really stand up and it's like in any in
any sport uh whether it be tennis or
football or whatever it's it's only when
the pressure is on that you see
you know how how much mental strength
how their aptitude is under those high
pressure moments what's the relationship
within formula one between like the two
top teams obviously all the attention
all the you know excitement is around
like mercedes and and you mostly and
then there's like a lot of other teams
and a lot of other drivers um
is that like 80 20 rule um there's you
are due to 80 of the rest is 20 well how
would you how would you like break that
down and what what's the role of like a
number eight or number nine team in in
your hierarchy internally
well i think um obviously it's an
intense rivalry and certainly was last
year between ourselves and mercedes
they're based
20 miles from from uh our factory um
there's a huge competitiveness between
uh between the teams and um
you know toto wolff and myself are very
different people we run the teams in
very different
different ways but that rivalry that
there's a respect
um but it's a hugely intense rivalry and
of course we've got you know ferrari a
phenomenal team so much history we
expect them to be fully competitive this
year
and and you know maybe one of
mclaren could throw a surprise as well
so
so uh
different dynamics but but like in any
uh like in any sport there can only be
one winner um
and uh
you know you've got different teams with
different different qualities and uh
uh
yeah you know ultimately there can only
be one winner but is it a completely
different business for like a number
eight team than it is for you i mean
they probably have like half the
resources they have like basically no
chance of winning at all um so it's a
different industry almost that you're in
and that are like a number
five six seven team is in well it's just
saying between um
you know a manchester city and a
and a
norwich city in the premiership you know
you have
a big uh a big difference and you know
whether it's in the bundesliga
you know as as well um so yes of course
it is a very different
challenge for the teams of fighting for
survival at the bottom of the field that
just by getting through the season is
their biggest result and still being
there compared to the teams at the front
of the field that uh it's all about
performance it's all about winning
uh and how far is the mercedes approach
and the total wolf approach different
than us and you just mentioned that you
both follow a different a different
approach
i think toto is uh
he's a much more corporate guy um
the the than i am um
he's a bit more remote from the team we
operate still very much as a race team
uh you know i'm here in the factory
today i'm in the fact if i'm not at the
racetrack i'm in the factory
um and uh i think that
you know we run as an agile team that
has the ability to to um
respond quickly react quickly
and be
you know very proactive in our decision
taking that we've been very agile in our
ability to take decisions and change
path or you know put path or direction
um mercedes have built a much more
corporate machine
um
and
you know as a result they're much more
process
probably driven
than we are it's not to say that one is
right or one is one is wrong they're
just very you know just very different
philosophies okay how did you um observe
yourself becoming a celebrity almost i
mean you have i don't know 1.4 million
people on instagram that follow you
you're like in these shows you're like
now like a global person thanks to
formula one thanks to to red bull how
did that develop for you or what how did
that change your life
uh
i i mean obviously working in formula
one within the formula one world
everybody knows who you are i think the
biggest difference now is because of the
global reach of formula one
um and things like you know netflix show
suddenly your face becomes a lot more
familiar um
and so that is
you forget that you know you forget that
you're just a normal guy you know doing
doing your job and then
you know somebody wants to come up and
have a
selfie or a picture in it
you're still surprised it still
surprises you um i mean my wife
obviously has had to deal with that
throughout hers
i know i know yeah so uh
but it's you know we're just incredibly
grateful to the fans and without the
fans there is no formula one so uh
i will always take the time to
talk to it to the fans or take a picture
or or an autograph because uh you know
without them there is there is no sport
but it feels like i mean the top names
in formula one if you like ranked them
it's obviously lewis hamilton then it's
max west up
and then it's almost like toto and you
that are like the the faces of the of
the sport and even though you're not
driving i mean that's that's basically
like a new development in general to
that sport or is that a wrong perception
i think it's just how things evolve and
i think it's the competitiveness between
the teams and uh and the drivers and
uh
[Music]
you know the the higher you rise the
sharper the knives become um so so
you know you've always got to keep your
feet on the ground okay okay well but i
mean but you like managing your
instagram account now appropriately and
you're like you know you do you do
personal branding deals yourself i mean
is it do the brands work with you
exclusively
no no everything i do is through uh is
through the team so uh
you know we have some great brands that
we that we work with but it's you know
obviously digital media is a great way
of keeping in contact with the fan base
and uh
it's
it's so accessible it's so
so immediate it's uh it's a great way of
communication
what's the kpi that red bull looks at i
mean they invest a lot of money they set
it all up um obviously now it seems like
they they get you know a lot out of it
but i mean they don't look at that blunt
they want to like probably know like
more details they
what's that what's the steering kpis
that that you have to work against in
order to make red bull happy um
they don't want to just win they want to
like get
something back for the investment right
yes but the the on-track performance
drives all the all you know all the
returns
so the key kpi is where we are on track
because that dictates everything else it
takes your television time it dictates
uh you know all you know all the
financials
um so the biggest thing that we're
engaged on is on our performance because
it drives everything else
so you don't you don't keep track of
like how many eyeballs you've reached
like every day every week we generate a
huge amount of data and so you can
always measure that and and there's no
substitute for winning
which one do you look at that i mean
like outside of winning i mean obviously
that's that's like the the sport itself
but like is there any like metric that
you look at that you like following like
oh wow that's that's bigger than before
like that's dropping off like what do
you follow i think uh fan engagement for
us is is huge and i think we
we're seeing that we now have more
followers in formula one than any other
team
um across the different platforms across
the people that we're engaging with and
also the demographics of who we're
engaging with is is incredibly important
you know for us that it has to be
inclusive
so um
you know obviously we're generating all
of these metrics which is all
fascinating fascinating data uh
but the biggest thing that drives that
is
how you perform on track and how you um
you know how you handle yourself okay
you mentioned that you've met i mean
bernie ecclestone very early on in your
career and he
tried to convince you to get into
involved in in formula one
how do you
perceive the whole development in
formula one itself obviously it doesn't
you know it's not a bunny echo zone run
business anymore it's belongs to
investors now um
what did change there
but obviously bernie you know such an
incredible character he built the sport
you know he created the business
he took it in the 19 early 1970s from
uh almost amateur status into a global
business generating billions of dollars
worth of revenue um
as a as a truly global championship
um but as anything in life you know time
moves on and it evolves and i think
uh obviously the business was sold to um
to liberty media and they brought in a
whole new approach uh
opening up
uh being more inclusive in terms of
their digital media strategy
uh in terms of how they work with
partners and sponsors and i think that
you know the world keeps evolving it
keeps changing in the way that people
look at content these days is very very
different to what it was 10 or 15 years
ago or certainly when i was growing up
that you know so much more choice you
know when i grew up in the uk there was
four channels
now
now you've got
you know millions of channels plus
youtube and i look over how my children
look at content or they look at sports
or they they interact it's very
different to when i was
you know to when i was a kid so um
and i think liberty have
have embraced that and i think you know
that's that's been a positive thing
can you like pinpoint one or two or
three decisions they've taken that that
that were different from from the bernie
eckerdstone era um i mean maybe that the
other sports can learn from like like in
terms of rights or what what were the
most striking differences that they
allowed or that they wanted from you or
that they how they how did they change
the game i think the biggest thing was
that they embraced digital media they
saw you know bernie uh always questioned
digital media because
he didn't see it as a revenue generator
whereas i think um
liberty saw it as an advert to then
drive eyeballs and and interest in the
sport so it was just a different
philosophy um
you know bernie was very much always of
the view he was
selling steak not not hamburgers
and
you know so for example the netflix deal
um
he would have never have entered into
because the
the revenue that they pay for those
rights
is is
very modest
but then you look at
the the
reach that's created
and then the the secondary revenues that
that's created for example
you know i don't believe we would have
bought oracle in as a title partner
without you know that that initiative or
all the promoters are full
um
you know
sold out audiences and looking for for
bigger
you know bigger grandstand capacity so
um it's just a different different
philosophy it's a different you know
different way of operating
and and um
does he like agree with that today i
mean you seem to talk to him once in a
while still i mean
i see i see bernie uh
you know regularly and you know he's
still very much
uh in touch
uh with what's going on with the sport
he obviously still has a great
relationship with all the promoters with
stefano dominicani now as a ceo of uh
formula one he has a good relationship
with so he's uh
yeah he's much more um
prevalent now than than he was say four
or five years ago
um and then how is your relationship to
to liberty i mean i mean obviously like
you're an important part of their
product and vice versa um how is that
relationship and how is the i mean how
often do you talk to them what's how can
you imagine that
it's very good um obviously i don't need
to talk to them so much um
i'm my main interfaces through their ceo
you know stefano who i've known for
for 20 years you know racing against and
uh
you know when he was at ferrari
um but you know chase carey greg murphy
all those guys um uh
you know they they're keen to see
formula one succeed and um it's great to
see that they still have a real passion
for it
in terms of global expansion what's the
next step i mean um obviously there's
like the us border seems to and i mean
obviously that seems to be like now uh
formula one market after decades
is there like another
market another expansion level that that
you're looking at well we've got to get
back into china um
so it's it's really important
i think it's a market for us uh i also
think
you know there's other there's so many
race places that want to host a race
whether for example south africa or
you know a desperate
uh you know to host to host the race or
even argentina you know other latin
american countries um
so yeah i think formula one is in a
great position that it can also be quite
choosy
about where does it want to host its 23
races in a year because of so much
competition from different markets
what do you hear here in terms of teams
i mean there's rumors there might be new
teams stepping in i mean even german
brands
i like at least you know in the rumor uh
anything that you hear there
obviously lots of discussion going on at
the moment and it's great the formula
one is generating that interest and it
just shows the relevance of formula one
so uh
i think the more prestigious brands have
been involved in formula one the better
okay but you don't expect any any
newcomers soon
i think the most obvious entry point is
2026 with a whole new engine
okay and so you know 2026 we've got a
new engine new chassis new car new
concord agreement that would be the
obvious entry point for any any new uh
manufacturer
i mean one of the obvious questions is
um i mean with all that success and all
the um
uh yeah development that you that you
see it it sometimes seems a little
contradictory if you can say that to to
like what's happening in the world i
mean everybody is like it's very climate
conscious it's very like thinking about
um
the the carbon footstep and the
footprint and all this um
is is that i mean surprising to you
yourself that like formula one is doing
so well in in these times
yes but we're also taking it very
seriously so um you know when you look
at the efficiency these cars are quite
incredible uh
in terms of the range and fuel
consumption that they're achieving with
the performance and horsepower they're
delivering is something that we're very
bad at promoting um you know from an
efficiency perspective of course we're
introducing you know bio fuel uh content
this year which will go up to 100
sustainable fuels in 2026
uh
so i think formula one is a as a
development bed for technology has
demonstrated time and time again with
some of the best and most talented
engineers in the world
um
that there is a driving force
uh of technology but but you still like
if you would agree that if you do a swot
analysis of the formula one like one of
the major weaknesses or threats is that
it has this i mean it's hard to argue
that it's very very climate
conscious
i think it's something that's the key
thing on our radar and that's why the
new engine and powertrain has
been a lot of collaboration with the
manufacturers to say okay does this fit
your criteria and i think the
overwhelming response has been yes
particularly with the use of
uh sustainable fuels with an increase in
electrification
hybridization so i think that uh
yeah that's a key factor that we're you
know we're very conscious of
do you follow the developments around
different racing series around like
electric vehicles all that is that
something that could also be a threat to
you um from a from a distance i think
you can see you know electric racing
isn't really working it doesn't engage
the
um
there's no noise there's no passion
there's no
atmosphere really to it and you now see
manufacturers withdrawing you know from
that from that championship so
um
i think it's great as a technology
you know tester
um but again
sometimes that technology has to be
questioned when you've got diesel
generators charging
you know charging batteries sometimes
it's
what's going on behind the garage
doesn't represent what it's representing
in front of the garage
okay okay
which which what do you see like closest
to i mean what do you compare yourself
to i mean you mentioned the olympic
games the soccer world cup any any like
other sports that you look at like the
nfl from your football in the us
anything that you try to learn from that
you look at that it's maybe even a
competitor i think you can always learn
from more sports i think that uh i think
american sports they put on an
incredible show it's about real
fan engagement and uh and entertainment
you only go look at the super bowl
you know for you know for that and i
think you could always learn i think in
in any in any business it's important to
be open-minded
um to look at other sports and uh
never feel that you're an exclusive club
that that knows everything
okay but so so you say football is
probably the best managed sport like in
terms of attention and global brand
worldwide
i'd say you know football is
uh very inclusive isn't it i mean
anybody can kick a football and i think
uh
uh you know football you see such a big
following globally for i think you know
formula one after that probably
you know is is probably the second
biggest sport in the world
okay okay i mean that's the problem with
racing right i mean it's so hard to
imagine what it's like so so for you
people have this experience i mean it's
it's it's like not it's not like
compared to car driving it's it's
something it's a as a sport nobody's
ever done it i mean it feels like
there's been like billions of people
watching it but nobody has ever done it
um
yes but then it's also about you know
these these incredible drivers that are
almost like modern day gladiators that
strap themselves into these unbelievable
machines and then
go and race each other at
ridiculous speeds i mean it's
uh
it's mind-blowing and particularly when
you see these cars in real life
the energy that they have the
performance that they generate the
you can't believe that a human being can
control it at that at that speed they're
like fighter pilots there was a lot of
talk here in germany because there's a
football game now coming to germany for
the first time an nfl game is going to
be played here i mean you have that in
london as well um is it
like
is this the live event like attending
enliven is that important to you or is
it basically a tv sport and it doesn't
matter
you don't really need to go because the
experience
on the tv is better than that in the
live venue i mean
what's the role of the live venue i
think it's a combination of both because
i think people feel the atmosphere from
the from the uh to the live event so
it's got to create the right atmosphere
the right buzz because that then
transmit of course it's all about the
eyeballs but if
uh if it's not a
if it doesn't look like a venue that you
want to be at or you don't when you
watch the event think i'd like to be
there wow that looks incredible
uh that's what it needs to transmit
that's what it's got to convey is it
like that i mean do you think do you
hear that like people come there and
they be like okay it's a different thing
that's why countries like singapore or
abu dhabi
uh you know formula one is uh
such a
spotlight
for that weekend on that territory and
when you see the night race in singapore
the amount of people say wow that's i
want to go there
or um
oh boy or any of the other venues that
we
that we go to you know that
it's putting the spotlight on their
country
um for that period in time and of course
it's that's why
countries and states get behind formula
one to invest in formula one as an
advert for their own territory i mean
they pay a lot of money to to get a
raise i mean that's that's that's how it
works right i mean you have to like pay
like millions and there was a huge
discussion in germany because you know
we had like two races now then one was
taken away and then it came out like how
much money certain cities paid for that
what's your what's your favorite uh
race in the calendar
it's great races i mean there's so many
different venues but some of the old
school circuits
you know the best ones anywhere there's
a big city is
uh is a lot of fun so as i say singapore
is a great race
you know japanese circuit is
unbelievable the belgian circuit's
unbelievable um
but even other races
like montreal you know with such a a
vibrant city right next door to the
racetrack you know melbourne there's
there's so many great venues you didn't
mention monaco
monica i mean monica how can you forget
monaco so
you know again uh a phenomenal venue and
an experience
okay okay tell us a little bit about how
it is to to to do your job i mean you
travel like how many days in a year like
when the season's on like how many days
are you gone yeah i'm away i would think
about 150 days um so it's a lot of
travel it's a lot of uh time away from
family and and
and loved ones so it's it's tough it's
intense but um
yeah it's short intervals so it's not
we're not going away for a month on end
and then you know it's it's in and out
so you you travel for like for a week
around the i mean when there's a weekend
race you like arrive in that city like
four or five days ahead of the race no
i'd probably arrive on a thursday night
and leave sunday night
okay immediately after the race you're
out and um
and then you okay i have a couple days
at home and then off to the next race go
right okay and how much longer can you
do that
i'm still the youngest team principal
formula once at 48 so
i've got a few more years left
i mean obviously i mean like what's the
oldest one
i've got no idea who the oldest one is
but uh
yeah martin whitmarsh has just come back
and you know he's got a few
a few miles in the clock now so but i
mean is that your perspective like doing
it for the next 10 20 years
i think you have to take it you you can
never look too far
ahead i love what i do i
i'm happy doing what i'm doing
um
and
yeah you know certainly for the next
five six years i can't see doing
anything else
i mean sometimes it feels like a lot
hinges on certain decisions i mean like
right now red bull is really fully
committed it seems to that sport to that
thing but i mean like little tiny things
can change within a minute i mean if
like for instance ferrari mercedes they
decide to drop out it always feels like
like just reading the news like it's so
much you know um vulnerability there
whereas in other sports it seems more
steady is that a fair um perspective i
think in any sport you've got
vulnerability in any walk of life look
at what has happened you know in the
in the world over the last three years
um there's always vulnerability
and that applies to sport as well i
think it applies to any sport i i mean
like with the corona um
developments i mean that was like a
tough time but i think formula one came
out quite okay right i mean like there
was only one year we adapted we
created you know work together to create
a calendar and operate and move people
around the globe um safely
there's very very few cases that broke
out in formula one so uh and we managed
to get a championship going in 2020 and
a full championship in 21 and obviously
hopefully we're over the worst of it now
christian thank you very much um for for
coming on and and for giving us nothing
how long until the season starts
we've got about three weeks so we've got
one more test in bahrain and then um
and then we're there for the for the
first race so uh the clock is ticking
okay okay okay okay and and you you
think i mean there's only one goal and
that's like to defend the championship
right well we got number one on the car
this year the plan is to try and keep it
on there
so it's going to be very very tough but
i think uh with the team we have with
the drivers we haven't got a good chance
all right all right thank you very much
okay thank you very much indeed these
are podcasts
from portstars
by om air